und wir nun zugeschaltet ist jemand erst
für uns auf lesbos die diskussion hier
in deutschland geht also immer weiter
wie viele menschen hier aufgenommen
werden können wir am gerade von paul
bird angela merkel will jetzt deutlich
mehr aufnehmen
er hat diese nachricht bereits die
flüchtlinge auf lesbos erreicht und wenn
ja wie haben sie darauf reagiert
nein diese nachricht nicht allerdings
ist tatsächlich so einige kennen wissen
dass ich aus deutschland und familien
aus syrien die ihren vater
also es verdächtig so doch dass sie viel
hoffnung wir haben und die 150 waren
nicht genug sie wollen ja alle nach
deutschland und es ist auch nicht so
dass sie verstecken die leben wir hier
alle anderen aufgaben straße und
glücklich ich bin eben noch mal im neuen
lager vorbeigegangen weiß stehen da will
keiner rein sagt egal was für einen
eindruck macht denn dieses behelfs camp
auf dich die tage sind vollkommen in
ordnung das ist sauber aber auch seine
tonsprache neubau am anfang verschlafen
jetzt geht der garten ist eine
demonstration von kindern in st die
busse lassana diarra villa park ganz
scharfes freiheit unten
sie sagen sie wollen freiheit also von
diesen leuten betreut obwohl ist
von außen betrachtet so gut aussieht die
fis toiletten dort gibt es wasser aber
diese leute haben angst dass wenn sie
noch einmal eingehen soll ich hier
rauskomme
vielen dank
findet jemand für den moment für uns auf
lesbos dankeschön
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bet schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren